my name is imanna bouzade i'm the ceo
and co-founder of incredible health
so i'm originally from sudan and i've
lived in several countries including
saudi arabia the uae and the uk
i moved to the u.s when i was 24 years
old both my grandfathers were
entrepreneurs and so i'm a very
you know risk-taking person and also
both my parents are immigrants as well
so they really instill the importance of
hard work and
whatever you choose to do make sure you
do it to the best of your abilities
healthcare is the biggest labor sector
in the country our demand for healthcare
as a country keeps going up as our
population is aging the supply of
healthcare workers has not kept up with
that demand another thing we discovered
as we were you know really digging into
this is that the software and the
technology and the processes and tools
that hospitals and health systems use
for hiring really hasn't changed since
the late 90s and so we figured there
just has to be an easier way i'm a
medical doctor by background i don't
practice at all
anymore but a lot of my family members
and friends are doctors and surgeons
they were actually complaining about
understaffing and they have and that's
been going on for many years and at the
same time my co-founder ron portlock he
has many family members who are nurses
and they are saying i'm experienced and
i'm qualified
but you know i apply to 10 15 places i
usually don't even hear back and if i
hear back can take a couple months
so incredible health is the fastest
growing career marketplace for
healthcare workers in the country
our mission is to help healthcare
professionals live better lives and help
them find and do their best work
hospitals and health systems they use
our custom matching technology to hire
high quality nurses in permanent roles
in 20 days or less the national average
is 90 days so we dramatically accelerate
that we already work with over 500
hospitals and health systems across the
country
the way we cut down the higher time to
20 days or less number one on our
marketplace the employers apply to the
talent instead of the other way around
the second is we've built pre-screening
and pre-betting uh technology that
automatically vets the talent uh and
then the third and probably most
important pieces are custom matching
algorithms so let's say you are a
recruiter at kaiser permanente or at
you know baylor scott and white or
jefferson health and you log in like you
don't want to see 200 nurses like you
want to see 11 that are the exact right
fit for you at the time
and that's what our custom matching
algorithms enable same thing from the
nurse's perspective let's say you're a
highly sought after icu nurse or or
nurse you don't want to hear from 100
employers you want to hear from four or
five that are the right fit for you the
other thing we're able to achieve is
dramatic cost savings for the hospital
so
for every facility that we work with we
save at least 2 million dollars in
contract worker or travel nurse costs
overtime costs and hr costs adoption of
the healthcare industry of technology
has changed dramatically especially in
the last few years and hospital
executives are much more open to
adopting technology that that makes
their operations more efficient so the
way i feel about running a high-growth
startup is you know not only is it
exciting but it's extremely motivating
you know our our mission is huge we want
to help healthcare professionals live
better lives we're trying to help them
find and do their best work what we're
all doing together you know our team as
well as with our with both the employers
and the healthcare workers is that we're
building we're defining a new category
and we're becoming the market leading
company in healthcare labor and we're
trying to transform this industry that
we're in and so that just means that you
know when there are bumps on the road
you just you know you just go right past
you know on a personal note i'm an md by
background and i think healthcare
workers are some of the most overworked
and under-appreciated workers in the
country and we just wanted to create a
product a service that gives them the
most delightful experience possible
because that's not what they're
accustomed to
you